let's bring in the two-time Wisconsin
sports writer of the year Rob dumansky
of ESPN's NFL nation we've been doing
this a long time Rob but I know yeah
yeah you know what then I was thinking
about that this morning and I'm pretty
sure it was 15 years ago probably to
this day that we were talking about them
drafting Aaron Rodgers to replace Brett
Favre do you remember what you felt what
you said about that strategy that day
yeah I remember thinking that I get it
because remember for how many years
Favre had been waffling about retirement
it was an annual thing with him starting
in like I don't know about 2002 or 2003
so they had several years of the will he
or won't he come back so I felt a little
different then than I do about this all
right how do you feel about this
surprised because Aaron Rodgers one has
said that he wants to play till he's 40
or beyond he's got four years left on
that 134 million dollar contract that he
signed a couple summers ago he's under
contract through the 2023 season and he
has never said anything about oh you
know if I win one I'm gonna hang it up
if this happens I'll walk away no
there's been none of that he admires
Brady he admires Brees he said that time
and again and the thinking was that he
would follow you know those guys in play
to 40 and Beyond knowing his personality
and you of course have been around him a
lot more than I have but I've been
around him socially and it feels like
footballs not a means to an end that
he's not one of those lifers like breeze
or Brady and I might be wrong in that
and also I viewed this as well if you
want to the Packers have to understand
his personality - how does this affect
him now these next two years and that's
where I think you probably go okay let's
let's get this guy maybe he's three
years away maybe this really gets Aaron
Rodgers pissed off and a pissed-off
Aaron Rodgers is a great great
quarterback what do you think of that
that
there's that there's definitely
something to that Dan there's two ways
that could go there's there's one like
you said they could it can put another
chip on his shoulder and you know how
long he's operated with a chip on his
shoulder it goes back to you know being
snubbed out of high school and having to
go to Butte College and then the draft
the whole thing falling you know from
what he was supposed to be 1 to 24 so
the chip on the shoulder thing is
definitely there it could spark him to
play as you know what off for the next
couple years but he's also a very smart
but calculating guy and you know I'm not
so sure that he that the other side of
it might be he might say you know what
screw you guys you're not helping me at
all here you know I'm not saying he's
going to ask for a train or anything but
I don't think it's going to sit overly
well you we would hear for years how he
was upset that they weren't signing free
agents that Ted Thompson was you know
not aggressive enough well here's an
opportunity you know to get him some
help offensively after a year in which
they come one game away from the Super
Bowl and they do this I can see him
being a little ticked off and not in a
good way does Aaron Rodgers end his pro
football career in a packer uniform you
know I asked somebody that knows him
that last night asked that exact
question and they said yes which
surprised me so maybe it speaks to your
point in that you know two three more
years and he says i I've got other
things I've got bigger things I want to
do look we know he's big into the arts
he is a smart smart guy well-read maybe
there is something more for him after
football we're talking to Rob dumansky
covers the Packers for ESPN NFL nation
here I also find this interesting just
like we saw with Garoppolo and Tom Brady
who share the same agent Rodgers in
Jordan Love are both clients of athletes
first the same agency awkward but they
don't share the same age by the way is
this that State Farm dude because that
State Farm dude is going to get fired
yeah that was one of the first things I
actually looked up this week when I had
heard that Jordan Love was on their
radar I said well I'll call I'll call
his agent see if there's anything to it
and I looked at it was athletes first I
said oh boy now it's a that's a huge
agency obviously as you know Dan but you
know it's it's not unlike the fact that
Mike McCarthy and Matt Lafleur also have
the same agent I also wondered this who
was going to swoop in and take Jordan
love it's one thing to take him because
you say he was the best guy on the board
and he fell into our lap he didn't fall
into your lap you went to go get him and
you moved up four spots who do you think
wanted Jordan love and you know made the
Packers flinch yeah my guess is that
somebody in the early second round I
think Indianapolis might have been there
and you know then there's the whole
Patriots factor you never know what they
might do so I would think it was one of
those two and I'm gonna guess that
you're gonna load up on skill position
players in round two for Aaron the
immediate response I was thinking would
be all right now you trade up in the
second round and get a receiver I mean
you probably get a good one at 62 where
they're sitting tonight but as a show of
good faith
don't you almost have to trade up to get
a receiver and abused Rodgers in some
way shape or form yeah or bring in Dez
Bryant that would be an option
thank you rob now gives you something to
chew on up there for quite some time
yep thanks dad appreciate it night bud
that's Rob dumansky